wie wir alle wissen als eltern kinder
können auch kraus haben seinen
mitschüler ausgrenzen verspotten
schubsen boxen wer kennt das nicht wir
waren ja alle selber auch mal kinder
allerdings ging es mir jedenfalls in der
fünften klasse noch nicht um
geschlechter toleranz sexuelle freiheit
gender politik mit elf jahren offenbar
ist das heute anders in einer realschule
in dortmund wurden drei mädchen von
einer horde mitschüler gemobbt und zwar
weil sie eine
regenbogenfahne seiten
[Musik]
scharf an einer dortmunder realschule
eine gruppe schüler außer rand und band
grund dafür drei schülerinnen die eine
regenbogenflagge mitbrachten das trio
will damit am ersten juni zum beginn des
pride man ein zeichen setzen doch ein
großteil der mitschüler hat damit
offenbar ein problem eine zeugen sagt
später aus die mädchen sei mit wasser
nass gespritzt und geschlagen worden der
schulleiter der robert koch realschule
schrieb in einer stellungnahme
die bilder machen fassungslos
man bedauere den vorfall zutiefst
auf den aufnahmen seien insbesondere
kinder der jahrgänge 5 und 6 zu erkennen
mit den betroffenen schülerinnen sei man
in einen intensiven dialog eingetreten
heißt es in der stellungnahme weiter
sprechen wir darüber noch mit nina grimm
sie ist der familien psychologin guten
abend ich
hab schon in der anmoderation gesagt so
mit elf jahren
wenn ich mich zurückerinnere ist schon
ein bisschen her da gab es solche themen
nicht prinzip ist das verhalten in dem
video ausdruck eines phänomens unserer
zeit
ich denke auf jeden fall das was schon
immer thema war dass sich die jugend mit
aktuellen gesellschaftlichen thematiken
gefasst hat aber in der intensität ist
es auf jeden fall neu und definitiv
ausdruck des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert welche auswirkungen hat
diese politisierung der gesellschaft
also das gender studies for future die
vogue bewegung all das ja eben auf
unsere kinder und wir reden hier ja wie
gesagt über elfjährige
also ich denke an und für sich ist ja
schon positiv zu betrachten dass eine
gesellschafts und anfang an den kindern
vermittelt das anderssein normal ist und
ich sage jetzt mal diese form der
identifikation
birgt natürlich sehr viel positives also
das ist man sicheren hafen sein kann für
menschen die da mit gleichgesinnten sich
austauschen können zeit leicht wird es
aber auch immer die gefahr dass sich die
identifikation mit dem dagegen geben
kann und sehr wahrscheinlich das was wir
hier in dem dortmunder video gesehen
haben genau das ist das was wir gerade
gesehen haben welchen einfluss hat weil
all dem social media
er definitiv eine ganz beschreiben aber
ich denke sowohl im negativen als auch
aber im positiven sondern also im
negativen sinn ist das natürlich so was
wie mobbing extrem viel leichter ist
wenn man so eine ahnung wie machen kann
schwimmen können social media gegeben
ist und nachrichten verbreiten sich
natürlich auch viel viel schneller aber
wie ich finde eben schon noch im
positiven sinn weil ich sage jetzt mal
homophobie rassismus und diskriminierung
hat ja immer schon gegeben aber heute
wird darüber gesprochen und das social
media also sehen wir es positiv
vielen dank frau
gretchen amt